[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24
rosa pérez mateo ya está lista con
nosotros en el estudio para hablar de
brasil vamos a tocar entonces todo el
tema de brasil porque ayer domingo
entonces rosa se vivió este primer
debate presidencial esto de cara a las
elecciones generales del próximo 2 de
octubre por supuesto tenemos entonces a
los dos protagonistas de estas
elecciones el ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva que es el favorito en
intención de voto en todas las encuestas
y el actual mandatario ya y
revolucionario que va por su reelección
honrosa el tema pues es de la corrupción
fue uno de los principales que usaron
para atacarse mutuamente también de las
ayudas sociales pero podemos más de este
debate rosa efectivamente buenos días
raúl este debate para resumir un poco el
formato es en esta forma que se llama
pool en que participan distintos medios
de comunicación entre ellos tv cultura
world of o la de sao paulo y vamos a
entrar aquí un poco en los titulares de
los principales medios de brasil
precisamente empezamos por el que decía
'la folha de sao paulo y como bien
comentaba es uno de los temas que
destaca en los titulares es esta tensión
estas acusaciones pues tan
características de cualquier debate
electoral precisamente la fue la de sao
paulo titula bolsonaro insulta a una
mujer en el debate lula escapa de la
corrupción y por otro lado este medio
también señala que el actual presidente
fue el principal objetivo o la principal
diana de los ataques de los
participantes que lula tendió la mano a
ciro gómez que rechazó el gesto y es que
ciro gómez a recordemos todavía alcanza
a protagonizar algunos de estos
titulares es el tercero en las encuestas
sin embargo va muy por detrás de los dos
digamos a principales candidatos y es
que recordemos que encabezando todos los
sondeos está el ex presidente y
candidato del partido de los
trabajadores a él lula da silva con una
aproximadamente 47 por ciento de la
intención de voto seguido de bolsonaro
que estaría cerca de la 32% mientras que
ciro gómez este candidato de centro
podríamos decir tiene entre unas 7 un 8%
de la intención de voto así que vamos
ahora con estado de sao paulo que titula
bolsonaro se convierte en objetivo de
nuevo o es atacado por atacar a las
mujeres y lula por corrupción y es que
lula recibió muchos ataques por el caso
petrobras que recordemos sin embargo fue
absuelto por la corte suprema de brasil
no que retiró las condenas que pesaban
sobre el expresidente correio
braziliense dice las mujeres se imponen
en un debate radical y misógino y es que
entre otras cosas bolsonaro atacó a una
periodista le dijo que era una vergüenza
para la profesión bueno igual estos
ataques a la prensa por parte del
presidente ya el personal ya no
sorprenden recordemos pues es bien
crítico con la libre prensa de ese país
y vamos con estado de miras
efectivamente que dice debate calienta
la disputa en el plató y es que incluso
digamos miembros de la campaña de
bolsonaro y de lula casi llegan a las
manos entre bambalinas seguimos entonces
con este primer debate presidencial en
brasil rosa que destaca o globo con el
que empezamos
saca una encuesta de datafolha que se
realizó digamos paralelamente al
desarrollo de este debate y es una
encuesta de las que se consideran
cualitativas con una poca digamos
muestra de hecho participaron 64
personas pero se les hace varias
preguntas no sobre los distintos bloques
que fueron abordando abordando los
candidatos y lo que destaca es que para
los votantes indecisos bolsonaro fue el
peor en el debate mientras que simón tvt
una senadora que también de hecho
recibió ataques misóginos de bolsonaro
fue la que tuvo el mejor desempeño sin
embargo recordemos esta candidata está
por debajo del 5% de la intención de
voto como el líder del partido
movimiento democrático brasileño que
dice carta capital rusa destaca entre
otros artículos las declaraciones a
finales de lula bolsonaro y ciro en el
debate nos vamos a centrar sin embargo
en las de lula y las de bolsonaro lula
por ejemplo alabó el gobierno de vilma
rousseff por otro lado también alabó su
fórmula vicepresidencial recordamos se
trata de gerardo alckmin que es ex
gobernador del estado de sao paulo y
líder del partido de la socialdemocracia
de brasil y dijo literalmente cito esta
carta capital que dijo de estaca de lula
destacó las consecuencias del golpe de
2016 mientras que de bolsonaro le dicen
que repitió los clichés de patria
familia y libertad bueno rosa dejamos
atrás entonces brasil todas estas
implicaciones y reacciones mejor dicho
de lo que fue este primer debate
presidencial de cara a las elecciones
del 2 de octubre para hablar de otro
tema también que está pues recorriendo
en este momento y es la visita de una
parte una comisión del oiea la planta
nuclear de sap orilla recordemos pues en
todo el centro del huracán y las
acusaciones mutuas entre ucrania y rusia
por los ataques que se han presentado
sobre todo a los alrededores de la
planta nuclear y pues los temores de que
uno de estos cohetes caigan unos
reactores de esta planta y pues ese pues
se desemboque
desastre nuclear rosa efectivamente y es
que recordemos que muy bien decías no
sería esa la planta nuclear más grande
de ucrania pero también de europa uno de
los escenarios más tensos de esta guerra
porque recordemos que la planta está
controlada por las fuerzas rusas sin
embargo operada por a funcionarios
ucranianos y como bien decías ante todas
estas tensiones estos bombardeos de los
que moscú y kiev se acusan mutuamente
finalmente se ha llegado a un acuerdo
para que una comitiva del organismo
internacional de la energía atómica como
bien decías vaya a supervisar el estado
de las instalaciones hay un poco a ver
cómo se protege esta infraestructura
clave y tan potencialmente peligrosa no
de sufrir un ataque sin embargo lo que
queríamos comentar es una mención que
hace el 'new york times' así como otros
medios de comunicación sobre la
formación de esta comitiva voy a leer
literalmente algunas de las líneas el
new york times dice la misión del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica incluye a expertos de polonia y
lituania naciones amigas de ucrania pero
también incluye expertos de serbia y
china miembros de países que ucrania ve
con un profundo recelo debido a sus
estrechas relaciones con moscú hasta
aquí digamos todo es bastante
comprensible sin embargo lo interesante
viene a continuación cuando dice los
miembros restantes son de países que se
han mantenido al margen de la guerra o
que han mantenido canales abiertos con
el kremlin como albania francia italia
jordania mexico y macedonia del norte y
a pesar de que por ejemplo sobre todo
macrón ha intentado mantener discusiones
con el presidente ruso vladimir putin es
digamos un poco difícil considerar
francia o italia países neutrales en
este conflicto